you know we want to make it a family
affair oh it's a family affair all right
Angelina Jolie is opening up about what
life looks like during the corona virus
pandemic I love being a mommy I love my
kids so I just stand in a rare interview
with Harper's Bazaar the forty five year
old actress opens up about what
quarantine has been like at home with
the six kids she shares with her ex Brad
Pitt you and your children are your best
friends it's kind of a it's a nice life
quote like most parents I focus on
staying calm so my children don't feel
anxiety from me on top of all they are
worrying about I put all my energy into
them
Angie also revealed that they expanded
their family during lockdown 11 year old
Vivian's pet bunny died so they adopted
two new ones they need to be in pairs
they are so gentle and it has helped to
focus on their care with her at this
time and on the dogs and snake and
lizard and with everything going on in
the world right now the Oscar winner and
global activists admits she's had a
reawakening of her own quote having six
children I am reminded daily of what is
most important but after almost two
decades of international work this
pandemic and this moment in America has
made me rethink the needs and suffering
within my own country what am i I'm an
actor so I make films then what am I and
my kid's gonna say about me what have I
done to help other people or do
something good to give back
Angelina adds that even though we have a
long way to go it's been nice to see
people rising together all over the
globe it feels like the world is waking
up and people are forcing a deeper
reckoning within their societies it is
time to make changes in our laws and our
institutions listening to those who have
been most affected and whose voices have
been excluded Angie's ex Brad Pitt has
also been vocal about his support of the
black lives matter movement the 56 year
old was spotted protesting in downtown
LA earlier this month
[Music]